[Applause]
[Music]
before we get started let's just pay the
bills right now or the walkthrough
[Music]
main street boxing gyms just to go all
the main street fighters come from 100%
as you can see there's a lot of bags
full size ring for your limping training
a lot of champions came in and out of
this place come here and train young and
old every bag imaginable
speed bag heavy bag full body bag full
size ring combat tote with the King here
we go I guess this is the first UFC
breakdown that I'm gonna give and I
really love the two combatants that's
gonna get in this room to Beebe and
Connor these guys are exactly the polar
opposites but the same and I will break
it down so you can understand they're
necessary
they represent the pinnacle of fighters
they represent the opposite directions
in which you can go to achieve the same
though they represent hard work
diligence pride and they behave as
fighters as all at all times at all
times
these men are exactly what they need to
be to achieve what they want now let's
take a beat for instance the record
speaks for itself
26 and oh that is unheard of in the UFC
I watched seven of both fighters last
fights they previous fights
and I took notes and I look for flaws I
look for pluses a lot for minuses
let's go could be first right khabib is
not that loudmouth
dude I mean he could be but he doesn't
speak to English doesn't speak English
well he speaks Russian and you know so
the translation doesn't come across good
you know he's not an entertainer but he
entertains he's everything that a UFC
fighter wants to be he has great
takedown
he has great ground-and-pound um the way
he moves on the floor is the way people
move when they standing up the way he
moves on the floor is the way of fish
moves in the ocean he goes from
transition to transition Wow at all
times keeping his opponent confused and
doing damage his whole mindset is to get
a hold of you and do damage with that
said those are his pluses like if if
we're rating it on all one to ten rating
as far as his fighting his ground game
is a 10 his movement is an 8 his boxing
is a seven maybe a six his defense is a
seven
his ability to absorb punishment is a
six now he's not allowed
will he pack arenas if you know about
UFC yeah
does the casual know about kabhi no the
casual does not know about Kirby and see
the face of the UFC
no he isn't the face of DLC will be nice
if he is but he's not now let's go to
Connor Connor is the ultimate
entertainer he watched Floyd he studied
Floyd in box and he studied the
highest-earning
fighter that he can compare yourself to
that he can achieve what the
highest-earning fighter will achieve see
because what Connor wants is kind of
once status
how does Connor wants to be seen above
all that's his driving motivation the
hunger the money the power the fame and
that's how his approaches his approaches
he's loud he's brash but he can back it
up
I don't ever think in your life that
Connor cannot back up his bold
proclamations and claims he has supreme
confidence in his skills but Connor has
to be losses so that means God has bled
three times now
let's go and look at what kana does well
Connor will be known as a striker Connor
if his striking the way he moves on his
feet like before the full Floyd fight I
would have said Conor was a nine because
his timing is impeccable
you don't teach timing to fighters
because timing comes with a sense of
fearlessness timing comes with a sense
of dominance timing comes with a sense
of knowing that if I deliver this shot
at this perfect time and it splits
seconds you see the door you see the
opening and bam it happens Jose Aldo
found out coming in kind of stepped in
and deliver the right hand seconds so
that's where you have that superstardom
that step that flash that bone Tana
delivers that in spades so the way that
Kirby moves on the floor and a grappling
Conor moves on a stand-up now since he
fought Floyd he had went through boxing
training I've been watching Conor his
training camps this fight his boxing has
stepped up immensely he throws hooks and
jabs the way he's supposed to he
sidesteps and he moves and he goes from
transitions to forward kick that is key
to back kick to spinning back hand to
spinning back elbow to lunging uppercut
- Superman punch - straight right hands
flawlessly now now he does so phone
grating Conor
his striking is a tent now if not a
10-plus his movement is always going to
be a nine he's like a snake like a Cobra
his takedown defense seven his ground
and pound seven his durability his
ability to take a punch and her last all
due to mental toughness that's a nine
his takedown game his ground game God is
probably a seven but seeing where khabib
as a plus Khan is a minus where Connor
is a plus khabib is a minus that makes
this fight so intriguing so incredibly
captivating because yeah it's very easy
to say if it goes the distance could be
ones Oh if it ends early condoms it's
very simple to say these things but this
analyze the rub this is the variables
that we are looking for as the viewer as
the fan the variables can Connor go to
distance can't kind of win the long one
pause King khabib knockout Connor quick
so these variables is what makes this
fight the must-see fight in the UFC this
year because you have the top two
fighters now Connor does not have belts
despite the fact that you will see him
taking picture with belts khabib have
developed
kebede is the champ Kebede is that do
khabib is the buggy man
he walks softly and carries a big stick
connor yells loudly and makes noise
wherever he goes so who would win my
kind of flash and Pan Am out early or we
employ what he did in his losses his
losses that he has and his one victory
to make Diaz we employ that strategy to
win see because what loss comes unless
it if you've never lost there's no
lesson for you to be taught with that
come to certain Hebrews but with that
also comes a certain mental toughness
because you believe beyond hope that
tonight is your night always but one
full run combat and he found out tonight
wasn't his night and for all his blows
stirring in and and bravado it wasn't to
be so I I believe in learning the pain
of defeat he also learned a powerful
lesson that victory is to be savored
victory is to be appreciated victory is
fleeting you don't know the horrors of
loss unless you have loss so going into
this fight I saw at the weigh-in let's
get this out the way UFC does not do
live wings alright you know they do a
live winging in the background they know
the weights of the fighters and
everything so by the time they step on
the scale it's just a formality okay so
it's little shock what's happening um so
at the weigh-in
I saw certain things that concern me
with Kaunas wait Kabhi wait won't be
issued to me unless he doesn't make
weight but Connor needs to be there fast
striking Cobra if he's off by a
milisecond in his speed that millisecond
can cost him because the reaction time
of khabib is definitely of a high
quality caliber I equate this to two
fighters Evander Holyfield versus Mike
Tyson
I always knew Holyfield would beat Mike
Tyson always the reason why is the
workmanlike fighter the fighter that
works on his craft that doesn't depend
on his natural god-given skills actually
produces when the time calls for it they
actually dig down and they actually give
you what a fighter is supposed to be my
prediction is could be by third round
stoppage
I believe kind of throws a kick and it
gets caught and could be he drives into
the floor and begins to maul him
with this caveat I am a conifer and I
know this is supposed to be an impartial
take on the two fighters going into the
ring I love exactly what karna has
brought to the UFC I love exactly the
businessman he is in the mentality that
he has I love that he has made it a
spectacle with skill and I truly don't
want him to lose but 26 and oh I want
that to sink in when these fighters in
the UFC age in dog years
it is unheard of to be 26 and oh I truly
do believe it to be 27 and north ended
us love for Conor to jump out and bam
take it but something showed me where
commas mindset was with to be the bus
incident you stand to make millions of
dollars fighting a person you don't go
on risk millions of dollars and you do
irrational things out of fear you may
not know it's fair but it's fair
nonetheless so the bus incident was
telling the confrontations when there
with each other is telling he knows
exactly who could be vis and Kebede
knows exactly who could be des
khabib is that guy he's that boogeyman
he's the name that you don't want to
come out of that hat when it's time to
draw could be even three
[Applause]
[Music]